foreign
[Music]
so this is Apple's brand new latest and
greatest iPhone 15. and nothing inside
is new or anything that we haven't seen
before in some other phone somewhere now
that doesn't mean it's not a good phone
you can actually be a really good phone
and not really new they aren't mutually
exclusive
and it turns out that is actually
Apple's strategy with this phone the
more I use this phone the more I see
Apple's textbook late mover Advantage
strategy coming into play here they're
going to take something we've literally
already seen before
and then do it the apple way so on the
outside let's see how would I describe
this new phone's design kind of familiar
I don't know somewhat reminiscent of the
14. how does Apple say it
iPhone 15 has an all-new design that's
simply gorgeous
all new
all new really
okay I mean I don't know about all new
but this phone definitely inherits the
same looks and general design as last
year again but you know what's at least
partially new is actually the way it
feels in the hands so I said this in the
15 Pro review but they've done a good
job softening the corners here so it
still looks boxy still has aluminum
rails but it's more comfortable to hold
since these Corners aren't as sharp
they're a little bit rounded off and
then this is also the first glass-backed
non-pro iPhone with a satin back and I
am loving the satin back this is like a
nice soft touch frosted glass back here
I know there's a super complicated
process too to like get this single
piece of glass on the back to be two
different colors and two different
thicknesses and all that and I can
totally respect it
but honestly the colors this year are
super weak people were saying in the
last video the color grading must be off
it looks like it's white instead of blue
no this blue phone really doesn't look
that blue at all in almost any lighting
it's like one percent blue but either
way you can say between the aluminum and
the pale light colors these are also
probably the most fingerprint resistant
iPhones in years on the sides same
button placements same speakers
placements same mute switch no action
button on this phone honestly you could
probably use an iPhone 14 case on the
iPhone 15 but around the front new
screen well not new again but new to
this iPhone new screen you now get the
dynamic Island on the non-pro iPhones
this year which is very much doing the
hole punch cut out the apple way so the
notch is finally dead until maybe a new
iPhone SE brings it back could happen
but also slowly app developers have been
getting on board in useful ways over the
past year I already have a few favorites
now my airline apps giving me real-time
flight info my weather apps Uber Etc but
while we're up here talking about the
screen on this phone it's also brighter
it's up to 2 000 nits now which looks
awesome Outdoors
but also it's 2023 and this is an 800
phone that still has a 60hz display this
is actually really fascinating to me
it's so odd like on one hand for most
people buying this phone it's totally
fine it literally doesn't have you it's
a new Baseline iPhone have you talked to
someone who buys a new Baseline iPhone
they literally don't care it doesn't
matter it's not something they pay
attention to you could ask them right
now how many frames per second their
phone is and they wouldn't have an
answer just doesn't matter so just as
long as it works and it's all relatively
smooth like last year and a year before
and the year before it's totally a
non-factor I have actually literally
handed 120 hertz phone to people next to
a 60hz phone and even side by side next
to each other they can't see the
difference or if they do it's just like
oh that's a subtle thing that seems kind
of neat but they'd be totally fine
missing out on it so with the Target
demographic of this phone it's totally
fine
but on the other hand
Apple the richest technology company in
the world does stuff all the time that
regular people will literally never
notice that are subtle improvements or
changes here and there all the time like
when they switch these Baseline iPhones
from LCD to OLED displays do you think
any of these people actually notice that
or what about going from the a15 bionic
last year to this a16 bionic do you
think people are actually noticing the
differences here or what about when they
just added 5G to the iPhone and most
people didn't care like making subtle
improvements over time is what modern
smartphones are all about these days and
I would actually argue that a higher
refresh rate is more noticeable to more
people than some of those other things
like I think you could today hand me a
professional an unlabeled iPhone with an
a15 bionic and an a16 bionic and it
would take me quite some time to find
the real differences between them and so
that combined with the fact that it's
incredibly cheap and easy and reasonable
able to get to like eat at least a 90
Hertz phone isn't there a the new Moto G
is like 90 Hertz at a hundred and
seventy dollars or something like that
now I'm sure that's a horrible looking
screen compared to this iPhone it's 720p
with the brightness of a box of crayons
but still they decided to add that to
that phone because Motorola knew that
enough people would notice it and feel
that smoothness difference and it's a
higher level of perceived performance so
it's just wild to me knowing how easy it
would be for apple to make this even a
90 Hertz display
but they just refuse to do it because
they've attached the word Pro
to that feature it's promotion for the
pro phones and It just strikes me as a
tool just to sort of continue widening
the Gap as much as they can between the
pro iPhones and the non-pro iPhones and
they're happy to do it even if it makes
this iPhone 15 the most expensive phone
in the world with a 60hz display anyway
speaking of widening that Gap the pro
phones this year also got a brand new
a17 Pro chip but this iPhone 15 gets
last year's a16 bionic from the 14 pro
honestly the renaming of the pro chip
might be the most interesting part
because it implies that it's definitely
not going to trickle down to the
Baseline phone next year but either way
this a16 bionic here is more than good
enough in a phone of this price as far
as performance and handling everyday
tasks and gaming and flying around iOS
at 60 hertz and the one thing you
definitely can argue for 60 hertz would
be battery life because despite all the
issues floating around the battery life
on these phones has been pretty good so
I don't know if you saw it but Apple has
officially now addressed the Heat and
battery issues that some people
including myself have been reporting
with these iPhones so an iOS update is
coming and it seems like some specific
third-party apps like Instagram were
also having issues and those should be
getting updates too but on average the
battery life on my 15 has been better
than my battery on the 15 Pro and the 15
plus looks to have the best battery life
ever on any iPhone which is really
promising so that combination of the a16
bionic which is not new and 60hz screens
which are not new are giving you great
battery life also USBC is definitely not
new but here it is alongside all the
benefits that come with it from using
the same cable to charge everything to
plugging into more accessories like
monitors and keyboards and all kinds of
other stuff it is sad that the older
chip does mean there's no USB 3
controller so there are no USB 3 data
speeds it's still slow but honestly
unless you're using the pro iPhone's
camera features there's almost no nobody
here buying this phone that's going to
actually need fast data transfer anyway
so I guess you can give it a pass and
they managed to do it in the apple way
too they color matched the inside of the
USBC port with the color of the phone
and actually I don't know if you've seen
this they print the model number inside
the port so Apple really loves hiding
this in the most discreet way possible
you can actually really give some
appreciation to some of the clever
software features on the iPhone 15
because you could actually consider them
new so they added stuff like an ultra
wideband chip so you can find your phone
more easily with an Apple Watch or be
found on find my friends that's new they
also added these clever audio effects
and video effects at an OS level so they
work inside of any app so you can be on
a phone call or a video call or Google
meet or Zoom or whatever and flip on the
background noise cancellation and it
works really shockingly well it's very
very good so I'm on a phone call with
myself this is what it'll sound like to
be in a room with the dishwasher running
the HVAC showing
and the thing going right next to me
right next to the microphone when I
switch the mic from standard mode to
voice isolation mode
do you know all the same noise are still
happening it does a much better job of
just picking out specifically my voice
really smart
and it's genuinely new there's also some
other not so new stuff like they just
now added downloadable offline areas to
Apple Maps and interactable widgets and
they finally added an 80 battery charge
limiter in the settings so you can check
out all the stuff I did a full video on
the iOS 17 update at the link below that
like button if you want to watch that
you should definitely check it out after
you watch this video what I will say is
one of the most liked features I talked
about in that video is standby mode and
on the pro iPhone when you put on a
charger turn it sideways it keeps the
screen on which it can do because it
goes to one Hertz it's an ltpo display
and it's fine staying on like that but
on the non-pro iPhone which does not
have ltpo it's basically locked at I
think either 30 or 60 hertz either way
it doesn't drop to one Hertz so Apple
just decides we'll turn off the screen
after a little bit which kind of feels
like it defeats the purpose of this
feature so then you have to nudge the
table or bump the stand to wake it up
like an Apple Watch charger just a note
difference between the pro and non-pro
iPhones but last but not least these new
cameras
are actually weird but in a good way so
iPhone 15 has been upgraded to a new set
of 12 megapixel Ultra wide and the new
48 megapixel main camera it's not the
same sensor as the pro it's actually
slightly smaller but it has a larger Max
aperture of f 1.6 to make up for it and
then it's also doing a combo of binning
and detailed transfer to give you this
new 24 megapixel photo as a result by
default now if you're paying attention
before you'll remember that this new
iPhone has the exact same chip as last
year's Pro iPhone same processing cores
same image signal processor same neural
engine same a16 bionics same everything
so why is this new 24 megapixel default
only coming to the newest iPhone 15 and
not last year's Pro like I still have
last year's Pro phone and I've updated
it to the latest software and it does
not get this feature it's still shooting
12 megapixels so honestly now my base
iPhone 15s non-zoomed in photos are
actually looking a little little better
a little more detailed than last year's
Pro phones and then there's the new auto
portrait mode detection feature which is
pretty sweet basically you don't have to
switch to portrait mode to take a photo
that captures all the depth information
that allows you to turn it into a
portrait mode photo later so as long as
you're pointing the camera at a human
subject or a cat or a dog as identified
by the neural engine or if you tap to
focus you automatically get this little
F at the bottom corner of the screen
which means it's capturing the data
needed for portrait mode just in case
and so then later if you decide I
actually do want this to be a portrait
mode shot you go into your gallery and
just make it a portrait mode photo that
you can even then go in and edit and
play with some people have been
describing it as being able to change
the focus Point later it's not exactly
doing that you can't like save something
that was out of focus by bringing it
back but basically for the classic
iPhone shot where it kind of looks like
everything is in Focus then yeah you can
play with portrait mode and get really
good results last year's Pro iPhone has
the same chip also has a 48 megapixel
main camera and has the same neural
engine doesn't get this feature for some
reason
also kind of weird so look it's with
these reviews we always make a lot of
judgments about what we think the
typical iPhone buyer is what they
actually care about what they'll notice
what they will appreciate about a new
phone and with this one I do feel like
they've stacked up enough of these
subtle improvements that even though it
looks the same and there's not really
that much that's actually new here
they've at least stacked enough things
that it feels like an appreciably better
phone so my verdict is if you have an
iPhone 14 you don't have to upgrade of
course even a 13 maybe but if you have
an older phone and you're looking to
upgrade to a new iPhone every year I
always get friends asking like oh should
I just get the older like last year's
iPhone to save some money and no I
actually wouldn't I would say just get
the iPhone 15 there's enough new changes
here it's a better phone in every way
and it's also USB like you don't buy a
base iPhone to get the bleeding edge of
tech you buy it just because it works
and it's fine and it's going to be
familiar and work for the next few years
and just knowing that you're going to
have it for the next few years I would
not recommend buying a lightning iPhone
as we just moved everything forward into
the world of USB type c just get the new
one just grab the boring new iPhone with
nothing that's actually that new it's
just gonna work
that's it thanks for watching
get to the next one peace
[Music]